good afternoon vice president harris and
i
just received a briefing on the kova 19
by
our team of experts and
as we end one of the most difficult
years as a nation
i remain optimistic about our future
vaccines have been discovered and
developed and there's more to come we
believe
give us enormous hope our economy is
poised to come back
and come alive and i can see a return to
normalcy in the next year
i also see incredible opportunities for
our nation
in the rece in the years ahead in job
creation
clean energy racial equality and much
more
but we need to be honest the next few
weeks and months are going to be
very tough a very tough period for our
nation
maybe the toughest during this entire
pandemic
i know it's hard to hear but it's the
truth
as roosevelt said i think the american
people can take whatever we tell them if
we tell them straight from the shoulder
we need to steal our spines for what's
ahead
we need to follow you more closely the
recommendations to slow the spread of
the virus
and each of us needs to do what we can
to protect ourselves
our families and our fellow americans
we're going to get through this better
days are coming
but it's going to take all the grit
determination we have as americans to
get it done
so today i want to be clear about five
things every american should know about
our efforts to contain covet 19
and where the vaccine stands today
first things are going to get worse
before they get better
in september we passed a grim milestone
200 000 deaths at that time in this very
room many
remember i warned that we hit 400 000
deaths
before the end of the trump
administration in january
critics said i was being too alarmist
and negative
but as i've said all along i will tell
you like
it is when it comes to covet
and the reality is it looks like that
we're going to hit that grim
milestone we've just crossed 330
000 deaths in america we're averaging
daily death rates of nearly 2
200 people which means we'll lose tens
of thousands of more lives
in the months to come hospitals are
being stretched beyond capacity
and that's data before we see the impact
of the cases coming from the recent
holidays and this upcoming holiday of
new year's eve
people getting infected today don't show
up
in cases for weeks and those who persist
or should be those who perish from the
disease die
weeks after initial exposure so we have
to anticipate
that the infections over the holidays
will produce soaring cases
counts in january and soaring death
tolls
into february you know
turning this around is going to take
time we might not see improvement until
we're well into march
as will take time for our covet response
plan to begin to produce
visible progress the second thing
to know the trump administration's plan
to distribute vaccines is falling
behind far behind we're grateful to the
companies
the doctors the scientists the
researchers the clinical trial
participants
and operation warp speed for developing
the vaccines quickly
but as i long feared and warned the
effort to distribute and administer the
vaccine
is not progressing as it should a few
weeks ago
trump administration suggests that 20
million americans could be vaccinated by
the end of december
with only a few days left in december
we've only vaccinated a few million so
far
and the pace of vaccine the vaccination
program is moving now
as it if he continues to move as it is
now it's going to take years not months
to vaccinate the american people
which brings me to the third thing every
american should know
the biden harris administration will
spare no effort
to make sure people get vaccinated
i've laid out three challenges in our
first hundred days
one of them is ensuring that a hundred
million
shots have been administered by the end
of the first hundred days
if congress provides the funding we'd be
able to meet this incredible goal
it would take ramping up five to six
times the current pace
to one million shots a day but even with
that improvement
even if we boost the speed of
vaccinations to one million shots a day
it will still take months to have the
majority of the united states population
vaccinated i've directed my team to
prepare as much more aggressive a much
more aggressive effort
with more federal involvement and
leadership to get things back on track
we'll find ways to boost the pace of
vaccinations
but as dr fauci and others have stated
these past few days
this will take more time than anyone
would like and more time
than the promises from the trump
administration have suggested
this is going to be the greatest
operational challenge
we've ever faced as a nation but we're
going to get it done
but it's going to take a vast new effort
that's not yet underway
and to get things uh and you know and
that gets me to the fourth
thing that we should know i'm gonna move
heaven and earth to get us going in the
right direction
i'm to use my power under the defense
production act when i'm sworn in
in order and order private industry to
accelerate
the making of the materials needed for
the vaccines
as well as protective gear vice
president harris and i
have been speaking to with county
officials
mayors governors of both parties to
speed up the distribution of the
vaccines across the nation
we're planning a whole government effort
and we're going to work to set up
vaccination sites
and send mobile units
to hard-reached communities it's hard to
reach communities
and we also know there's a vaccination
hesitancy in many communities especially
black latino native american communities
who have not always been treated with
the dignity and honesty they deserve by
the federal government
and the scientific community throughout
our history that's why we will launch a
massive public education
campaign to increase vaccine acceptance
we'll do everything we can to show the
vaccines are safe
and critically important for one's own
health and that of their families and
the communities
that means we're also going to make sure
vaccines are distributed equitably
so every person who wants a vaccine can
get it no matter
the color of their skin or where they
live
and we're going to ensure vaccinations
are free of charge
fifth while the pandemic rages on
and as we increase the supply
distribution and
administration of the vaccine we have to
remain vigilant
as part of the 100 day challenge i'm
going to be asking the american people
to wear a mask for the first hundred
days of my administration
it's not a political statement it's a
patriotic duty
our administration can require mass
growing where i have the power
to do so for federal workers in federal
facilities
on interstate travel like planes and
trains
and we've been working directly with
county officials mayors
governors to implement mass mandates in
their cities and their towns and their
states
masking has been a divisive issue in
this country
but covet is a killer in red states and
blue states alike
so i encourage you all to wear a mask
encourage your family and friends to do
the same
it's one of the easiest things we can do
that will make a huge difference and
to save lives another 100 day challenge
is opening most of our
k-8 schools by the end of the first
100 days in the spring look
we can only do that if congress provides
the necessary funding so we get
schools districts communities and states
the resources they need
for those so many things that aren't
there already in a tight budget
they need funding for testing to help
reopen schools
more funding for transportation so
students can maintain
social distances on buses they need it
for school buildings for additional
cleaning service
protective equipment ventilation systems
this is going to require an additional
tens of billions of dollars to get this
done
and congress also needs to fund and
provide more protective equipment
for frontline health workers who are
still
reusing masks and gowns we need to scale
up testing
so anyone who needs one can get a test
after 10 months of the pandemic we still
don't have enough testing
that's a travesty all this
vaccinations testing protective gear is
going to require more funding from
congress
more than was just approved that's why
i'll propose a covet action package
early next year
and challenge congress to act on it
quickly
look my ability to change the
direction of this pandemic starts in
three weeks
with thousands dying every day between
now and then
let me conclude by discussing what needs
to happen
now i congratulate the bipartisan
majority on passing the presidents
and then the president on signing the
covert relief bill
it's still you know as a step an
important step
still moves in the right direction and
it will help people in need
and i'll it'll pay for some but not all
of what we need to fix the covered
response
it's a down payment but now
with that done i hope the president will
also
clearly unambiguously promote
masquerading
i give former governor chris christie
credit
he and i have disagreed in a number of
things
but i'm thankful he's now encouraging
people to do the right thing and wear
masks for themselves
their loved ones in their country i hope
the president trump will listen to him
he can do it too it would make a huge
difference for president trump to say
wear masks i hope the president will
clearly and unambiguously urge all
americans
to take the vaccine once it's available
i took it to instill public confidence
in the vaccine
president-elect harris took it took hers
today for the same reason
and when the president's doctors
recommend it president trump should take
it and it's still the same degree of
confidence
let me also say say this to the american
people
we can save all the experts tell us
between
60 and 100 000 lives in the weeks and
months ahead
if we just step up together wear a mask
socially distance wash our hands
avoid large indoor gatherings i know all
these are not easy to ask
but i'm asking you to make a sacrifice
you're already making tremendous
sacrifices every single day
it's hard on your lives on your
livelihoods on your kids on your
families
it's not small what we're asking of you
but we're in this together and the
actions we take now are going to help us
contain the pandemic
and get us back to our lives and to our
loved ones
so the american people to all of you
i know there's a lot that we have to do
but i want you to know there's also much
we can do
we're the united states of america we've
been through hard times before as a
nation
and we'll come through this as well i
promise you we will
so please i wish you a happy new year
may god bless you and may god protect
our troops
wear a mask